on a rarement vu un référendum avec de
tels résultats louis l'a emporté à 95,2
% hier soir à mayotte l'île va donc
devenir le 101e département français
mais pas avant 2011
cela va impliquer pas mal de changements
dans un territoire où une majorité de la
population ne parlent pas notre langue
ou la polygamie est chose courante et la
justice rendue par des dignitaires
musulmans ardent goûter on attendait une
victoire du oui
pas forcément un raz-de-marée à 95,2 %
mayotte île française depuis 34 ans
devient département et s'ancre un peu
plus dans la république
le département vieille revendication
marque un virage applaudi des deux mains
mais l'évolution sera progressive avec
les minima sociaux prévus en 2011 et
surtout l'apparition de nouveaux impôts
mayotte espère toucher des fonds
européens et certains électeurs les
réclament déjà avec détermination qu'il
nous faut c'est des milliards et des
milliards d'euros pour qu'enfin mayotte
soit développé le département modèle
laïque interdit toutes nouvelles unions
polygames ainsi que la justice musulmane
les clandestins représenteraient un
quart de la population
beaucoup redoutent que le nouveau statut
augmente un peu plus l'immigration
illégale
devenu incontrôlable
oh